[Musica]
non sono mai stata una persona
particolarmente coraggiosa o forse non
sapevo neanche di esserlo la verità in
quella molto spesso quando giocavo mi
ricordo di essere uscita più volte fuori
dal campo da tennis dopo una partita
perché ero arrabbiata con me stessa
perché non era stata abbastanza
coraggiosa da essermi andato a prendere
l'ultimo punto della vittoria di aver
aspettato l'errore dell'avversario per
paura di sbagliare e invece posso dire
adesso dopo qualche anno juncker smesso
e quindi che mi sono un po allontanata
da quello che il campo da tennis
io se posso dire di essere stata una
ragazzina una grande donna una donna che
ha fatto delle scelte e delle scelte
molto molto coraggiose per farvi capire
qualcosa di quello che di cui sto
parlando vi volevo far vivere tre
momenti pre momenti che secondo me sono
stati dei momenti fondamentali della mia
vita e della mia carriera
il primo momento sicuramente bisogna
tornare un po indietro bisogna tornare
indietro a l'infanzia ai sogni di una
bambina piccola e vi farò vedere adesso
per farvi capire questa foto mi dice
tutto questa mia piccolina sono io
questi sono i miei genitori erano avevo
parte mia sorella giorgia su un campo da
tennis naturalmente perché come
tradizione familiare vuole tutta la mia
famiglia ha sempre giocato a tennis e io
da bambina ho un ricordo di giocare ore
ore questa racchetta questa palla
ovunque e ovunque mi trovassi e avevo un
dei sogni volevo diventare una
campionessa volevo diventare una
giocatrice la più forte giocatrice
italiana di tutta di tutti i tempi
volevo essere quella che avevo attaccato
dietro la porta
nella mia cameretta avevo le mie icone i
miei idoli dovevo la capriati la seles e
io volevo diventare come loro
sapevo non sapevo se ci sarei mai
riuscita però l'intenzione c'era infatti
continuano quotidianamente a giocare a
giocare a giocare anche vestita non da
tennis come potete vedere con un vestito
molto semplice dalla domenica la la
decisione importante la prima edizione
importante lo prese a 15 anni quasi
quindicenne come papagna mamma seduti
intorno al tavolo abbiamo deciso di
andare a roma quindi di lasciare la casa
di lasciare mamma e papà a di lasciare
quelle sicurezze che una ragazzina può
avere e intraprendere questa questa
nuova vita
quindi poiché potete capire come mi
potevo sentire da una parte ero euforica
contenta e dall'altra invece avevo anche
tanta paura paura perché mi sarebbero
venute meno tutte quelle certezze quelle
sicurezze che magari a quell'età con la
ragazzina ha bisogno quello è stato un
momento super coraggioso sia da parte
mia ma anche da parte dei miei genitori
grazie a loro che mi hanno sempre
sostenuto
ho potuto affrontare tutto quanto se non
ci fossero stati loro sicuramente tutto
questo non sarebbe stato possibile
quindi non smetterò mai di ringraziarli
e questo è stato forse il momento che a
dell'inizio di una carriera una carriera
meravigliosa una carriera dura dove ci
sono stati tantissimi alti e bassi
tantissimo momenti dove sentivo di aver
finito di non avere più niente dalle
aree di sconforto di delusioni che si
alternavano invece momenti di gioia e
l'euforia incredibile perché purtroppo
nel tennis sono più le partite che si
che si perdono di quelle che si vincono
però è uno sport meraviglioso che mi ha
regalato veramente delle emozioni uniche
che cercherò di trasmettere ai miei
figli
il secondo momento di coraggio e questo
per me è stato un momento veramente
importante è avvenuto invece alle tre di
30 anni ormai una persona può pensare
che a 30 anni uno sportivo per uno
sportivo e un po essere vecchietti
passatemi il termine mentre per la vita
sei giovane
io mi sono ritrovata a 30 anni dopo le
olimpiadi di londra del 2012 con un po
il suo rotto il pozzo della mia mano
destra rotto quindi la mano dominante il
legamento totalmente rotto e mi sono
dovuta operare un operazione importante
un'operazione che non mi dava la
certezza di poter
tornare a giocare e quindi avevo fatto
anche delle altre scelte delle scelte
una scelta importantissimo è stata
quella di lasciare il mio allenatore
storico gabriel urpi che mi ha seguito
per sette anni in quel momento lui aveva
avuto una grossa offerta da una
federazione della federazione francese è
seduti al tavolino anche con lui in quel
momento quindi se flavia musa voti e
faccia che aspetto ho scelto questa
proposta io con la serenità totale che
potevo avere in quel momento di dissi
guarda gabin io vorrei finire la mia
carriera con te però in questo momento
non so neanche se tornerò a giocare a
tennis quindi accetta pure io vedrò come
come gestirmi da dove ricominciare se
ricomincerò dopo qualche mese di
titubanza di un po un po un lavoro
interno ho capito di volermi dare
un'altra chance e quindi ho avuto il
coraggio di rimettermi in gioco il
coraggio di ricominciare da zero
praticamente il coraggio di ritrovare
uno team un nuovo gruppo di lavoro che
mi doveva sostenere mi doveva aiutare ad
affrontare tutto quanto come se fosse
stato per la prima volta perché quando
uno smette per
stacca la spina per tanti mesi perde
tantissime sicurezze e certezze non sai
più se sarai all'altezza gli avversari
perdono il rispetto che fino a quel
momento hanno avuto sempre in due
confronti e quindi è stato un momento di
ok mi rimbocco le maniche
ricomincio mi do un'altra chance vediamo
se sono capace
era stato un percorso lungo un percorso
che è durato tre anni
anche questo è un percorso nel quale ho
sofferto tantissimo perché ho avuto
dolori costanti per un anno dopo
l'operazione
ma nonostante questo tutte le mattine
riuscivo ad alzarmi andarmi ad allenare
ea cercare un obiettivo quotidiano che
mi desse quella quella voglia di
[Musica]
continuare a lottare e così è stato così
è stato grazie all'aiuto di questa
persona
salva norma largo il mio allenatore e
massimo tosello il mio fisioterapista
sono stati loro che mi hanno piano piano
ricostruita mi hanno aiutata a vivere
fiducia in me stessa e mi hanno anche
scosso molto spesso è perché erano due
due personaggi molto forti ma io ho
sempre amato le persone
dure di polso ecco e loro mi hanno
aiutato a tirarmi su
mi hanno dato il coraggio anche loro in
questo caso mi ha dato ancora il
coraggio di ri credere in me stessa di
provarci e vedere dammi un'altra
opportunità
loro sembrano riceve alto datti
un'opportunità ha dato una chance
poi vediamo che cosa succede ed è
successo a una delle cose più belle che
potessimo immaginare cioè che ho vinto
due software e sono stata sul tetto del
mondo con questa coppa la coppa più
bella del mondo a mio avviso questo
naturalmente è l'abbraccio dopo la
vittoria con salvatore lui che vanno ha
smesso mai di credere in me che mi ha
sempre sostenuta e mi ha sempre spronato
e li penso che sia avvenuto
una cosa incredibile come tutti me la
fanno sempre ricordare soprattutto il
mio papà ago rosio che ancora oggi
soffre lì penso di aver avuto il
coraggio più folle se lo possiamo
definire che è una persona potesse avere
quello di smettere di giocare e quindi
di lasciare il mio mondo
nel momento migliore della mia carriera
ho avuto il coraggio di dire basta
ho avuto il coraggio di dire
sono in pace con me stessa ho ottenuto
tutto ciò che volevo adesso posso
veramente lasciare questa racchetta
lasciare questo mondo e ricostruirmi rir
inventarmi capire che cosa mi piace
oltre il tennis capire cosa non mi piace
quello che voglio quello quello che non
voglio è stato un momento di di
consapevolezza estrema un momento dove
tutto il mondo mi dava un po della pazza
perché nessuno pensava che una persona
possa fare un gesto del genere
in quel momento ma nessuno però capito
mai perché l'ho fatto io in quel momento
ho avuto dentro di me una sensazione di
pace e di tranquillità che non avevo mai
avuto fino a quel momento ho capito che
avevo abbiamo sognato fino a quel
momento tutto quello che stavo vivendo
ma ho avuto molto di più di quel sogno
da bambina che avevo e quindi per me era
arrivato il momento di dire basta
sono serena sono felice
voglio staccare la spina da questo mondo
e voglio diventare una moglie diventare
una mamma aveva un obiettivo era
l'obiettivo di volevo costruire una
famiglia una famiglia meravigliosa come
quella che che ho avuto e ho avuto la
fortuna di avere intorno a me e io non
smetterò mai di ringraziare la mia
famiglia tutte le persone che mi hanno
sempre sostenuta nella mia carriera
perchè molto spesso si vedono gli
sportivi si vede il campione ma non si
vedono ma che tutte le persone che ci
sono dietro di noi tutte le persone che
ci sostengono e che lavorano con noi
quotidianamente
io credo che senza tutte queste persone
non sarai mai potuta essere quella che
sono oggi
ecco ragazze il messaggio che io vorrei
mandarvi oggi quella di di credere
sempre in voi stessi di non aver paura
di prendere delle decisioni ed essere
coraggiosi a prendere delle decisioni
importanti e lasciar magari molto spesso
anche quella sicurezza che 1 a del
vecchio per qualcosa di nuovo e sempre
difficile a charlot lasciare la vecchia
strada per quella nuova perché non sai
mai quella nuova tipo dove ti porterà io
credo che anche negli errori e quindi in
questi momenti di coraggio dove uno
sbaglia perché è umano sbagliare ed è
giusto anche sbagliare perché dagli
errori secondo me sì si impara
tantissimo sono quelli poi che ci
rendono quelli che siamo
quindi io vi incoraggio ad essere
coraggiosi a continuare a sognare ea lui
presentato i propri sogni